est ce qu'on voit c'est que dans les
lycées ça parle que de parcours su parce
qu'on a peur
[Musique]
un premier changement majeur de parcours
su que ça va être le calendrier c'est à
dire que jusqu'à présent l'an dernier
les candidats ils pouvaient avoir des
propositions d'admission jusqu'à la fin
août
donc ça fait que bas il ya des candidats
qui se retrouvaient attendre tout le
mois d'août sans savoir où ils allaient
aller là le ministère a décidé que la
fin de la procédure parcours su que ça
serait le 19 juillet donc au 19 juillet
les étudiants ils seront au clair qu'ils
sauront s'ils sont prêts dans une
formation dans quelle formation ils sont
pris et puis s'ils sont pas pris ils
auront les mois la fin du mois de
juillet et le mois d'août pour trouver
une nouvelle affectation
une deuxième décision c'est un
raccourcissement des délais de réponse
c'est à dire que quand on se connecte le
premier jour sur parcours sup
on a un certain nombre de jours pour
répondre aux premières propositions
qu'on a reçues et l'ancien calendrier
donné sept jours pendant plusieurs
semaines
puis trois jours puis une journée là
l'idée parcours succès que ça va être
d'abord dans une première phase cinq
jours plus répondre et puis ensuite dans
une deuxième phase trois jours pour
répondre alors la conséquence c'est que
ça va sans doute améliorer et accélérer
le processus c'est à dire que les
candidats devront répondre plus vite
mais ça veut aussi dire qu'il vaut
devront être beaucoup plus réactif parce
que ça c'est un point de parcours succès
qu'il faut à peu près se connecter tous
les jours sur la plateforme pour voir si
son dossier évolue pour voir si on a une
nouvelle proposition d'admission
parce que si on passe à côté d'une
proposition on perd tout est
potentiellement on n'a pas de place à la
rentrée il ya un autre changement qui a
été fait par le ministère et qui je
pense va dans le bon sens mais qui est
assez audacieux sa part c'est la mise en
place d'un répondeur automatique
en fait à partir de la fin du mois de
juin les candidats ils auront peut-être
potentiellement un certain nombre de
propositions mais ils auront aussi des
voeux en attente
hélas le ministère a dit à partir du 25
juin il sera possible de hiérarchiser de
classer ses voeux en attente c'est à
dire un potentiellement si on prend un
exemple on est admis en médecine mais on
a en attente une fac de droit
et puis une fac de bio qu'on a envie de
faire eh ben on pourra dire dans les
voeux en attente j'ai premièrement envie
de faire bio deuxièmement envie de faire
droit et si on reçoit une proposition à
une des des offres inde et veut qu'on a
fait il sera possible d'être affectés
automatiquement
donc les étudiants n'auront plus à se
connecter tous les jours s'il le
souhaite c'est quelque chose de
facultatif c'est la mise en place de ce
répondeur automatique
le but c'est d'éviter que les étudiants
aient à se connecter tous les jours sur
parcours sup et l'autre but du ministère
c'est d'éviter aussi que
les étudiants ça a été observée l'an
dernier garde des voeux en attente pour
rien et alors une dernière nouveauté qui
a été annoncé la très récemment sur
parcours citant c'était vraiment la
semaine dernière c'est la mise en place
de trois points d'étape c'est à dire que
les candidats au mois de juin et puis
deux fois au mois de juillet devront se
connecter sur parcours sud quelle que
soit leur situation
et même s'ils ont mis en place ce
répondeur automatique pour dire un peu
où ils en sont la conséquence par contre
plus négative c'est qu'il faudra
impérativement que les candidats se
connecte à ces trois moments clés parce
que sinon ils risquent de perdre tous
leurs voeux et puis il ya eu d'autres
annonces qui sont encore plus fraîches
encore plus récentes notamment il y
avait un débat très épineux autour de la
manière dont parcours suggéré à
l'affectation dans les facs en
ile-de-france faut savoir que il y avait
un critère qui était un critère
discriminant sur parcours sup qui
faisait que quand on était élèves de
banlieue parisienne
on avait moins de chances qu'un élève
parisien d'accéder aux licences à la fac
donc à toutes les filières non sélective
de la fac c'est quelque chose qui a été
très critiqué notamment par un sénateur
qui s'appelle laurent lafon et qui a
remis la semaine dernière un rapport au
ministère qui disait qu'il fallait
mettre fin à cette discrimination des
élèves de banlieue qui voulaient accéder
à des formations à paris et lui proposer
qu en fait toute l'île de france soit
une même académie et que qu'on habite
dans le 16e arrondissement dans le 11e
arrondissement ou bien dans 93 on est
les mêmes chances d'accéder aux facs
parisiennes mais aussi d'accéder au fac
en seine-saint-denis et en essonne etc
bref que finalement toute l'île de
france soit une même région aux yeux de
parcours super et ça le ministère l'a
acceptée donc cette année il n'y aura
plus de discrimination à l'entrée dans
les licences en ile de france l'an
dernier sur parcours suffit à des élèves
qui étaient classés 3 centièmes cinq
centièmes sur liste d'attenté qui
pensaient qu'ils n'avaient aucune chance
or quand les formations appelle les
candidats il leur arrive très
régulièrement de descendre bas dans les
listes d'attentes donc les élèves
parfois n'attendez pas jusqu'au bout
démissionner voilà donc il ya eu une
grosse incertitude autour de combien de
temps il faut attendre cette année les
candidats sauront quel était le rendu
derniers candidats admis l'année
précédente sur parcours sucre dans la
formation
concrètement un candidat qui est classée
400e s'il se rend compte que l'an
dernier le dernier admis ils étaient six
centièmes il se dit bah j'ai mes chances
et je peux attendre
al'inverse il est classé 8 centièmes et
que le dernier candidat admis était
centièmes ça sert pas ça vaut pas le
coup d'attendre
un autre point moi qui est un enjeu
crucial et c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'il faudrait faire c'est la
transparence sur les algorithmes locaux
qui sont utilisés par les universités et
par les formations sélectives
il faut que chaque prépa chaque bts
chaque dut chaque licence disent
exactement comment les candidats sont
triés l'objectif
il est double ça permet de lutter contre
un sentiment qu'ont parfois certains
candidats que peut-être que les critères
sont opaques il ya des discriminations
je pense que ça n'est pas le cas mais ça
permettrait de faire la lumière là
dessus
et puis ça permettrait aux candidats
aussi de savoir s'ils ont leur chance
d'être admis ou pas et puis un autre
point là je pense que c'est plus de la
vigilance qu'il faut avoir avec parcours
suppl le ministère a annoncé la création
d'une plateforme qui s'appelle ory sup
et orrit sup en fait c'est une
plateforme une grosse base de données
qui va recueillir pendant 15 ans toutes
les données des étudiants donc les
données sociales
les données démographiques géographiques
les notes les résultats et c'est pendant
quinze ans dans une grosse boîte noire
au ministère les données de tous les
candidats qui seront passés par parcours
sud vont être retenues et là ça a été
même pas très m'annoncer très
officiellement moi je les ai découvert
un peu par hasard en lisant un rapport
fait par un comité qui travaille au
ministère il ya un gros point de
vigilance il faudrait peut-être plus
d'explications sur le fonctionnement
plus de pédagogie et moi je pense
qu'aucun candidat aujourd'hui qui ne
s'inscrit sur parcours sud est au
courant que pendant 15 ans toutes ces
données vont être stockés